jetzt geht es richtig los ausgerechnet
europa wird die erste hyper look strecke
in den künftigen ausmaßen gebaut also in
originalgröße und so die sie dann mal im
regelbetrieb funktionieren soll das
ganze passiert in frankreich in toulouse
dort hat das unternehmen hyper lufti ein
forschungszentrum eröffnet und fängt
jetzt mit dem bau der strecke an alles
über den größten fortschritt des hyper
lobs jetzt index um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen
es ist soweit und ich bekomme ein
bisschen gänsehaut der heime look
startet und das ausgerechnet in europa
was beim transrapid von den ersten
planungen bis zur ersten teststrecke
jahrzehnte gedauert hat das geht hier
wirklich in windeseile vonstatten und
dazu war der transrapid eine einzige
fehlplanung 2002 wurde die erste
kommerzielle strecke in china eingeweiht
aber zu laut zu hässlich und er
verbraucht zu viel strom die folgen er
verkehrt nur mit wenigen passagieren
fährt 0 so schnell wie ein ic weil der
strom sonst zu teuer wäre und er wird
nicht weiter gebaut und das bei einer so
vielversprechenden technologien der hypo
nun scheint die nachteile des transrapid
zu vermeiden die idee ist auch viel
einfacher und ziemlich genial und solche
ideen machen auf den unterschied aus
manchmal ist es wirklich papieren dabei
ist die idee für den hyper look wirklich
super einfach rohrpost und die könnte
der magnetschwebetechnik jetzt im
nachhinein zum erfolg verhelfen das
prinzip der zug oder beim heimklub eine
kapsel wird in eine röhre gepackt und in
der herrscht ein vakuum bzw ist kaum
noch luft enthalten ein sogenanntes teil
vakuum hochleistungspumpen pumpen die
luft aus der röhre und erhalten das
vakuum der effekt es gibt kein
luftwiderstand mehr das hauptproblem und
der energiefresser jedes schnellen
transport mittels er ist einfach weg
damit brauche ich für den zug kaum noch
energie ist der einmal beschleunigte
sollen solarzellen auf den
transporteuren ausreichen um für die
energie zu sorgen mit rund 1200
kilometern pro stunde soll er zwischen
metropolen verkehr schneller als mit
einem flugzeug und eine neue
magnetschwebetechnik ist geplant weil
der deutlich weniger energie verbraucht
wird permanentmagneten die im
sogenannten holborn angeordnet sind
sollen zum einen die magnetkraft in die
kapsel nahezu auf null reduzieren und im
gegenzug unten zum transport track
verstärken
in dem track heißt die technik die von
hyper lob transporttaschen technologies
angewendet wird und ihre teststrecke für
diese technologie wird jetzt eben gebaut
erst mal nicht besonders sagen dann als
20 meter die röhren haben einen
durchmesser von vier metern und sind
damit für güter und auch schon für den
personentransport geeignet die ersten
röhren fertig und werden bereits an
ihren bestimmungsort gebracht dieses
jahr noch soll die tests
gefertigt werden und im sommer schon das
erste testfahrzeug das würden auch in
europa in einem werk in spanien
gefertigt und im nächsten jahr würde es
dann richtig amtlich dann wird eine ein
kilometer lange teststrecke gebaut wird
karbon ceo von hyper lucchetti dazu bei
haifa not geht es um mehr als schnelle
beschleunigung unserer sprechen von
geschwindigkeitsrekorden es ist eine
echte chance ein effizientes und
sicheres system mit einem einzigartigen
erlebnis für die reisenden zu erschaffen
und das ganze geht natürlich mal wieder
man muss sagen natürlich
selbstverständlich auch wem zurück auf
ihnen maske er hatte die bahnbrechende
idee aber gab sie frei jeder darf
entwickeln und bauen macht hält sich
vollkommen raus und besucher vielleicht
mal die verschiedenen standorte der
konkurrenten denn auch virgin chef
richard branson ist mal wieder mit am
start er hat das zweite unternehmen das
am heimflug dran es gekauft ausflug
wurde virgin
es bleibt also extrem spannend wenn er
als erstes neues zum thema hyper lob und
zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt
dann endet meine telefonnummer hierbei
whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor
allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich
garantieren kriegt auch meldungen außer
der reihe
und zur begrüßung gibt es noch ein
kleines geschenk einfach hier
draufklicken und topaktuell dabei sein
und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
genau glocke vergessen hier geht es
weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken hyper
luke deutsche strecke geplant ansonsten
bis dann bleib dran